No, this is for my grandkids, and it's Grandpa's story.
There's a buzz in the air.
It's a bee over there.
It's just above it Helen's big fluffy hair.
It's flying around Chuck in the old wooden chair.
It landed on April, and she fainted right there.
The buzz passed the swing set, and over the fence, just a circle again, how it doesn't make sense.
He's spoiling our picnic and scaring the baby.
He whizzed past the table right over the gravy.
Round the tree, here he comes, with more speed than a car.
Close your mouth, squint your eyes, for he's not very far.
Zoom, he goes faster than I can keep up this riddle.
Look, he split Johnny's part in his hair, down the middle.
There's a buzz in the air, and he's flying by Pa, who's cutting grass with the lawn more chewing up son.
Run in the house, or hide under a rock.
I think the buzz has just summoned his flock.
He's after the watermelon, or something more, grab the chips, the cupcakes, and head for the door.
Susie just screamed, and plopped down in her chair.
A mother was tempted to leave her right there.
Grandma's dress turned all red from the drink that Sam spilled, and she jumped and tipped over the jello while chilled.
That it bounced off Anne's face.
On her nose left some cream, then proceeded to splat on her lap.
Oh, some cream.
There's a buzz in the air.
He just flew around the corner.
We thought that we were all through with the horror, but no sooner could Anne cleat off her pants.
Then I looked up to see one giant army of Anne's.